what's good man it's dallas martin
president of asylum records here at the
boule cave podcast
yo boo like head podcast we got a
special guest in here man the homie
dallas
he's here yeah i'm smart man welcome
brother happy to be here
yes um first of all we gotta get the mic
close to your face am i closer
yeah there we go i'm not used to you
know having the mic so close i know
artists so
yeah welcome man um you know i i feel
like uh
the last few years you really
established yourself as like
one of the most powerful dudes in
hip-hop yeah that means a lot man
yeah man you know on the executive side
the a r side
um for people who don't know at this
point in time what is
what is it that dallas does and what is
it that cause you have so many titles at
the moment yeah it's got a new title
you know what i'm saying yeah so so
right now um i'm president of asylum
records and um you know it's a label um
underwater music group which also has
atlantic records
warner brothers records and a lecture so
they gave me
my own um you know my label inside the
situation but
with this situation i still carry my
title at atlantic as far as i'm evp of a
r so i'm still on the executive team
over there so
what it really is is that the asylum
label is more of a
upstart incubator system for me to sign
kind of more development acts
accept i just truly believe in that i
feel that our talents it
that i have to develop then once i
develop them and get them some spark
i could upstream them to atlantic to me
and give them bigger budgets you know
just a bigger um company to kind of help
you know push their vision forward so
you're on like both sides of the coin
yeah so you upstream to yourself yes
yeah that's [ __ ] crazy so i could go
downstairs
sign it and take
exactly so it's very unique man but you
know just giving me an opportunity to
work with more people that
you know i wasn't able to work with just
being at atlantic because you know
atlantic's such a big label with so many
big artists yeah yeah
um you know it's hard for you to be a
new artist with nothing going on and get
attention at that label
so you know this just creates a a bridge
for opportunity for young artists
um for people who don't know where are
you from i'm originally from flint
michigan
okay and um i went to college in atlanta
georgia and that's where i started my
music journey yeah give us a
bit like like kind of a background on
how you got into the music industry
so my whole goal um to go to atlanta was
to get into school at clark atlanta
because i wanted to get into music that
was like my dream from high school
and um i knew that atlanta was um you
know a city that was up and coming with
a lot of entrepreneurs in the music
business
so i went down there got into school and
um you know just
worked um every year trying to figure
out a way to get an internship you know
during that time it wasn't no social
media
and easy avenues to break into you know
get even getting an internship like
nowadays it's more easy you know the
internet and just
you know things that come about but when
i was coming up we had to go to like the
open mics
yeah workshops the a r workshop
you know get played by mad people who
really didn't really want to be there
giving you fake information and [ __ ]
like that so
i realized after my sophomore year i
needed to get on my grind
and figure out a ways to bring people to
me so that's when i started throwing
parties in college
okay and it kind of led me to an avenue
where i was meeting executives
and then i in my senior year i finally
got an internship with shakira stewart
at def jam
wow okay so what year was this so i
didn't get an internship to my senior
year i was about to give up
so you were throwing parties what year
what yeah yeah to my senior year
like what year like 2 000 so i got into
school
um 2002 so i got my first internship in
2006.
wow it's crazy too because um
you know i feel like a lot of people
start throwing parties yeah
and that's how they get into the into
this [ __ ] yes like scooter brawn like
that's how he got into this [ __ ] yeah
in atlanta probably around the same time
absolutely yep scooter was around i mean
i remember him bringing justin bieber to
the death jam
office for the first time when he was
like 13 years old
so like it's just a lot of dope memories
from that era i mean atlanta was just on
fire
oh yeah that was like vintage jeezy
tip luda everybody everybody was just
crazy
um if fast forward so you end up
interning
at def jam and by the way i just had a i
just had to go on twitter were you
getting paid to intern
absolutely not okay cool i just want to
make sure because there's this thing
going around on twitter
about uh unpaid internships and i'm like
uh unpaid internship literally changed
my life mine too
and i and i did it for two years for
free i did it for 14 months
fresh out of high school with a newborn
baby i was trapping at the swap meet
selling bootleg cds on the weekend
and working for free money through
friday yeah i feel like the
entire generation that we're a part of
like that we see coming up now
they don't even know what this like yeah
it's an entitled
is this entitlement thing with these
with these guys with these young kids
man it's instant gratification nobody
wants to work for nothing anymore
everybody wants to be rich as the person
that put them on immediately
it's crazy another thing too is like
i've saw people on twitter like man i
interned here for for a year and nothing
happened after i was like well cause
obviously you ain't had it bro like
if you if you if you were that if you
were that dope and you were putting in
the work you need like it's just gonna
work
like i literally got to the um office
before my boss didn't left after him
every day
me too man like i wanted to make sure he
knew that
i wanted this [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah that's
how i was a radio like
even when i started to get paid i would
be at the radio station doing the
morning show for free
from like four in the morning until
about 11 a.m yeah then i'd go do a
street hit which is when i finally
started to get paid so i'd be doing that
[ __ ]
all day check this out then i would do
my overnight
so i would literally go home and sleep
for like four hours i'd be at the radio
station
you know 18 hours out the day just just
grinding i just feel like
that's important for people to
understand like this [ __ ] ain't like
like we we really work to get where we
at bro and i think you know when you put
that
that level of hard work ethic into you
know the structure
of your daily life like it shows why you
know people like us are where we're at
today
you know what i'm saying because we know
what it takes to get there that's some
real
important yeah yeah um so you started
the intern what was your first paid gig
in the music industry so um from my
internship
shakira stewart gave me a consultancy
with def jam
um so from that consultancy i got to
work on projects that he was working on
so my goal was to work on everything he
didn't really have time to work on
um so i used to just just be in the
studio every day and he had a
r b group that um he was working with
and i i ended up getting their first
single
so from that situation we're trying to
be group was it it was they were called
brother
back in the day i think i remember they
had one song with fabulous they were
brothers they had a show on bt it was
it was okay it was it was quick hey if
they would have been out now they've
probably been popping on youtube with
their family and [ __ ]
okay yeah they were like this first one
reality tv really kind of got right
right
in the music [ __ ] um so you know i got
opportunity
and you know um la reid got to see my
value
and from there um i got hired full-time
in um 2009 at def jam wow
yeah january 2009 he brought me out
full-time so that was like
0-9 this is like when rihanna really
started to like
she was running the label for sure yeah
that was like when rihanna first was
like a superstar yeah she was only a
dream
yeah yeah yeah rick ross yeah um
it was it was good times over there and
how
what what year was j was jay running
deaf children they left that
shakira took his um not ticket spot but
was promoted
into that position after he left and
shakira passed away committed suicide
and that's what happened that's how i
got with l.a reeks larry kind of brought
me on because he knew what was going on
with me
so because i was in atlanta and
everybody was in new york and you're
what was your title in 09 when you got
i'm just a
director of a r just a regular the
lowest level of a r you could get
i'm 24 years old on my [ __ ] death jam
as an anr couldn't believe it i'm from
flint michigan you're living in atlanta
i'm living in atlanta going to new york
every week
wow living the dream couldn't believe it
first time in new york i'm going to the
dev jam building sending in the
[ __ ]
a r meeting with dj khaled right tricky
and dream
lenny yes [ __ ] just crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] was mind-blowing
i think that there's a very uh
define what an anr does because i think
that
people who are just watching this who
might not be involved in the music
industry they hear that term so much
they don't really understand what it is
so anr has multiple things that you have
to be good at
so a lot of people think and are just
hearing a song on a radio be like that's
a good song
or i saw an artist and he's dope what
people don't understand is once you
sign that artist you have to help them
put their project together
right make sure that they have the right
songs to put out
then you have to deliver that album that
means get your artist to give you the
project to be like this is it i'm ready
to go
in the public with it right you know
what i'm saying jesus christ
um so the hardest part of a
r is getting your artists to deliver
their album you know what i'm saying
because their projects their baby and a
lot of time
artists are insecure with their music at
some points in it
and you know that's a big thing for you
no very vulnerable situation for artists
to give music to the world for the world
to critique them
of course um so you know just different
levels
of of a r and you know the record-making
process
is is a big part as far as knowing the
right writers
producers and people just to put um in
the studio with them
so you'll you'll come to the table and
say hey i think
uh this person would mesh well with this
person so like let's put you in with
this producer for
yeah and see what comes out of you
absolutely and you know
you have to be there in the studio with
them to make sure that you know because
they're not going to come and be like
best friends
right right you're kind of like you're
kind of the middle man yeah so you have
to make sure that everybody's
comfortable with the creative process
but you have to know
the creative process from both sides the
artists and the writers and the
producers to make sure that
everybody could come together you know
make magic together which is the hit
record what year did you
officially come to atlantic so
i got fired after my first year at deaf
gym okay
because i couldn't deliver a album from
an artist that was on there
which artist was it it was um joel
santana my brother i love him shout out
juelz
okay you know what i'm saying he just
was in a position where he didn't like
what was going on at the label i don't
think it really had nothing to do with
me
but um he wasn't confident um in them
you know what i'm saying and we and we
still remain and good friends and have a
good relationship
um but la reid um he he let me go
but you know it was during the time that
the music business everybody felt like
was crashing
so the budgets were getting smaller um
the opportunities were getting
um smaller you know what i'm saying
because it wasn't a lot of money coming
in this is when um
napster and you know all the piracy was
really at a high level by the way did
you else ever turn in that album no i
was about to say because
if that was like 2010 i'm like
nah i'm like did that he never did but
you know i don't recall that yeah but so
it didn't work out for me with that
situation you know what i'm saying
and you know i learned a lot from that
situation
and it was no hard feelings you know so
i didn't
you know i took a month to kind of just
regroup in atlanta then i just got back
on my grind
and um got a phone call one day um from
joey ie
and he set up a meeting with me um he
told me he was um
relaunching the urban division at warner
brothers records
which eventually turned into atlantic
yeah um and he gave me a uh
interview and an opportunity uh from
there
so that was the era when
mmg went to warner brothers so yeah so
so i had a relationship with rick ross
because shakira signed rick ross and
jeezy
so the first two albums rick ross did he
recorded in the
um in the office where i interned yeah
okay so i built a relationship with
strong relationship with him and um
gucci pucci
um so you know they just saw my come up
and you know i would shake little guys
so you know they always kept their eye
on me
um so when i got to warner brothers the
first day on the job i just called ross
like
you got to bring maybach over here it's
wide open you know so you're you were
very instrumental in bringing that oh
absolutely
because me and ross was super tight you
know i pretty much
like you know joey helped me put it
together because joey was the boss so
you know it was like you know my
relationship but you know
obviously you know you got joey todd
moscowitz and lyra cohen who are the
chairmans and people who are running the
company and i'm i'm the
you know the lowest level a r so you
know through my relationship i brought
the meeting to them we had the meeting
together
you know rick ross expressed to them you
know how important me being involved
with it would be if he did the deal
there
and we got the deal done two weeks later
i remember how big of a deal that was
because i remember
you know my boy lee was over at warner
brothers and
lovely love that guy yeah good guy there
was like no hip hop though it was
nothing
it was like yeah it was like it was like
dry as [ __ ] it was jill scott i think
and then and then uh mmg coming over at
the time ross is the hottest thing
moving yes
meek is the hottest thing in the streets
yeah and people in wales
and then even was moving
absolutely and and i just remember that
moment was so big
bro yeah that's history yo so they so
you i didn't even realize i didn't even
know that you you helped bring that
situation over yeah that's what like got
me to
start it as far as just getting some
credibility because from there you know
me and wale did lotus flower bomb yeah
and
put out wales project that did super
well when number one
then from there um i did meek dream
chasers 2
and dreams and nightmares and i pretty
much did every mmg project
that came out on the warner brothers
system until we even transferred over to
atlantic
yo so when uh when you first heard that
well first of all were you
around when the dreams and nightmares
intro was recorded yes we was at the
setai hotel
i gotta hear this story because out like
this is a song that
will forever get played every single
club you go to
yeah one of the greatest rap songs ever
created
yeah yeah so it was crazy because
we was all on the high from the dream
chasers 2 mixtape
classic it was incredible you know what
i'm saying it was like we made that
project in l.a at the boom boom room and
like
that was probably like the funnest
project i ever worked on on my life
because that was like we're all just
coming up and
we learned we moved to la we're living
in l.a now
you know and it's just like the studio
we had it was just like great energy you
know what i'm saying and this before
like instagram took off so like of
course of course
a lot of the women that were instagram
big models this day were like you know
just around hanging out with us it was
just
great energy made that project
then me goes on tour and they like well
we need an album we like
we still got three or four songs coming
out from this mixtape
so um me gets off tour and we had ross
house and he plays was like the
beginning with the strings and all the
piano we like
what the [ __ ] is this you know this [ __ ]
is crazy so then
he um was like yo but this is what i'm
gonna do right here in this party stop
that i'm gonna have to be bullied do
this
part boom boom so then like two or three
days later we have the setai hotel
and he got the beat finished and he just
went in the booth right and he like kind
of surprised us
and that [ __ ] hold up wait a minute oh
man
[ __ ] was crazy and like we knew right
then and there that that [ __ ] was a
smash but
we ain't think that [ __ ] was gonna be
like one of the biggest songs yeah it's
crazy because when you hear that record
you're like this is a great intro but to
ever think that that's like a record
that would work in the club
yeah you would never think that yeah
cause we would have went with that for
the first single
and also you would never even think to
go for that as you said like
there's no drought is the first single
no hook no nothing
so it was interesting but you know man
listen man everything happens for a
reason
so what was the the the first single
from now i'm young and getting it yeah
that's right
young and again yeah yeah yeah who was
it who's on kirko banks
oh wow cause i was aiming on his project
at warner brothers
wow yeah that's crazy and he had like
two
joints that were number one so i'm like
drinking my cup yeah kirko's a very
talented kid man
so it was good time shout out kirko
cobains man
you know so you you kind of helped
spearhead that mmg movement on the a
r side and i do remember when
everything kind of moved over to it at
uh atlantic yeah
is that when you kind of went over to
atlantic yeah so what that happened was
you know joey left for def jam a year
later then the year after that we was
there for two years todd moskowitz
started his own
um company with leo at 300 yep yep yep
so
with warner brothers the landing and
everybody being understand under the
st my umbrella which is when her music
group they just merged
all the urban staff and urban artists to
atlantic
yeah and then it was like macklemore at
warner yeah
yeah yeah it was right warner was a wrap
it was a rap
sure so atlantic then we just you know i
went into working with julie greenwald
craig cowman and mike kaiser
and um they really helped like bowl me
as executive you know what i'm saying so
i really you know appreciate them
because they really you know took me
and um you know kept my path as far as
where i was doing they like kind of took
it to the next level
what was the um i want to definitely get
to you working with nipsey but what was
the first
um project officially at atlantic that
you were
a part of uh so i signed k michelle okay
because i was like let me do some r b
[ __ ] real quick so they want to just
stick me in this am
in our box and a marion post to be oh
yeah
so smash yeah so we did post the beat
and k michelle
had two number one r b albums from
reality tv shows so everybody was
flipping out
because now it's like are you doing r b
[ __ ] now i met her in new york
and uh i couldn't believe the size of
her ass
shout out to her man yeah man i took a
picture of it i was like
this is this is interesting hey it's
crazy because k michelle i feel like is
like one of the most prolific r b
singers
man 10 to 15 years like very time like
we got to put more respect on her name
for sure yeah man she's
she's very talented man for sure she's
very fun to work with man and you know
she just keeps going though um talk
about
nipsey coming over to atlantic because i
know he was on atlantic for a while but
it wasn't like announced
well no yeah so what happened was so
i started the process of trying to sign
nipsey when i was at warner brothers
okay he didn't want to sign of course
was that when there was conversations
about ross trying to bring in
mmg absolutely okay so you were part of
those conversations part of all that i
was bringing him to miami
we were doing sessions and by the way
ross was trying to sign everybody he was
trying to sign
wiz yeah uh ross had a good job montana
yeah everybody yeah we really wanted
nipsey and don was like
we wanted to settle the west coast with
them which i was like big
that would have been big for us like to
this day like i still wish in my heart
that happened because
everybody what i want everybody
understand like you guys everybody can
still have their own companies
and do their thing like with me they
were dream chasers and
like well i always tell everyone ross is
like one of the only examples of an
artist
who became an executive that did it the
right way because he
i feel like he genuinely wanted every
artist on his label to be bigger than
him
yeah and i think that's the problem most
of the time when you have artists sign
another artist
in their heart of hearts is some ego
[ __ ] involved they really don't want
their artists to be bigger than them
yeah
but ross i feel like was like his heart
was in the right place
yeah and it kind of showed like what the
success of the label
before we get to nipsey like kind of
give me that backstory about
how close the nipsy and dom [ __ ] was
because i always heard
nipsey and dom were very close to going
to mmg i mean
you know the talks got um you know very
intense
um you know um deal structures were
talked about you know things like that
um but you know one thing i could say
about nipsey and dom
they were very keeping their brand and
what they were you know
um what they were developing on their
own was very important to them and they
didn't want that to be overshadowed
so i think them just being you know
their own bosses were very important to
them
and it was like you know 100
understandable
when they didn't want to do the mmg
situation you know it was more so of a
uh
you know we just all wanted that [ __ ] to
happen because we just know how dope
that [ __ ] could have been but
you know at the end of the day they made
it this decision to do their own thing
which you know still worked out for them
so
was was wiz ever close to doing the
mm-hmm i don't think whiz was ever close
okay
yeah cause i remember what was that uh
currency and wiz was doing music
what was that what was that remix with
neo that yeah
all right so you had already been
talking to nip
prior at the warner at warner how did
the you know
the dope [ __ ] with knit man you know
nips really about you know just um
he's a real solid person so if you just
honest with him and direct and
i just kept a relationship with him even
though he didn't do the deal and i think
that's what made him [ __ ] with me even
more because it was just more so it's
like i just
made sure i sent beats to him i mean i
was like cause i just was a fan and of
course of course
um and i always tell them like bro
whenever you want to do something bro
just let me know i'll make sure that i
structure it the way you want to
like i know what's important to you as
far as your masters and [ __ ] like that
and so when i went over to atlantic
stevo was
a over there too and he was um managing
he just started the process of managing
um nipsey yeah
so me and um stevo worked together
really hard
to um you know figure out how to get him
over to atlantic but one day nip just
called me out the blue
like what you doing today right like
[ __ ] nothing
you know saying what's up he like me uh
let's go to lunch i'm like back meet me
at the roosevelt in an hour
all right and we sat at the roosevelt
for an hour talked about what we wanted
to do and
[ __ ] i want to say like two or three
weeks later we had another meeting with
craig calm and i had craig fly out to la
we sat down at the uh [ __ ] one of them
expensive hotel the peninsula or some
[ __ ]
and we sat down with nip and ironed out
the deal structure and
[ __ ] what's your history 2014.
yeah i'm telling you like a lot of
people don't realize nick it took us
three years to do the first project
and it also like he was so careful about
announcing that
yeah we kept a real hush like because
you know i think a lot of people in the
industry knew but like he didn't
announce it publicly until
yeah a lot of a lot of people in the
industry knew um i think a lot of people
um
wasn't aware of like how important his
first project
that he delivered because he still put
out mixtapes people don't remember like
during the time
mailbox so he still was staying active
and working hard but
you know he really had a vision of how
he wanted his major label release to be
and it just took some time to do it but
you know what was so dope about our
relationship was
i never pressured him you know i made
sure that he had everything he wanted to
make sure that
he could deliver the project he wanted
so you know my whole thing was just
making sure that he had everything he
needed
wait we got to take a break in the
interview real quick to mention our
sponsors
odd socks listen if you are uh into
comfortable socks on your feet amazing
underwear on your ass
and or fly ass masks on your face make
sure you go to odd socks man the most
comfortable socks in the [ __ ] world
oddssocksofficial.com when you check out
use the keyword bootleg kev and you'll
say 20
off they got some crazy licenses pimp c
mac dre
mike tyson rocky scarface wwe
whatever the [ __ ] you want they got then
they got the odd socks basics they got
all kinds of ill [ __ ]
all right and i'm telling you i wouldn't
be telling you if i didn't actually wear
the [ __ ] myself and all i do is wear odd
socks
i got some on my ass right now i got
some on my feet as well
all that so go to oddssocksofficial.com
keyword
bootleg kev altogether and you'll say
20 off at checkout oddssocksofficial.com
go [ __ ] with them victory lap was uh
obviously classic um
and and the attention to detail that you
just spoke about
that's why i always appreciated nip i
feel like everything he did had
intention and it was always on purpose
it was like
he understands what it means to have a
debut rap album yeah
and like how important that is to
deliver on because he's a hip-hop head
too you know
so the process of ua like helping with a
r in that album walk us through that
because there was like
some records on there that were just so
like
you know like hearing belly on double up
you know what i mean like like
like like what did you bring to the
process because nip
obviously had his his the way he made
records but i feel like there were some
records on victory lap that were just so
like
yeah elevated from anything we'd ever
heard from him before
so it was dope about the whole situation
you know mike and keys
um in 1500 man they were like the the
producers that kind of laid out the
foundation for the project
um and i remember one day like
i brought him hustling motivate you know
and i remember just being there and his
eyes lighten up
like when i played on the beat for the
first time and like
we talked about him being in the 6-4 in
times square with hove in the passenger
seat like just talking like
it was just like before he recorded that
song it was like that was like our first
record we did together
wow you know what i'm saying so you know
it was just like little thing but more
so
it was just like beats like you know
nipsey liked to just have beasts that he
[ __ ] with and he respected just my
opinion
on verses and structures the songs and
things like that but
you know that [ __ ] was pretty much all
put together
with nipsey's vision were there any um
records
because you hear rumors and stuff but
were there any uh features that were
supposed to happen or
or that that didn't end up happening for
on victory lap
no not really i mean i think the biggest
thing was important to him was the
kendrick feature
right yeah and and that was cool i mean
jay-z of course everybody
wants that but you know with jay-z
everything happens for a reason of
course he got the song with jay-z now
that's amazing
of course puffy getting puff puff daddy
to talk [ __ ]
was that something that was uh was that
like a hard thing to get him in there no
so what happened was the album was done
yeah and he wants to go play it for puff
and i think puff was just so inspired
when he heard the project that he had to
put his fingers on it you know
saying in his ear and his touch on it
and you know
nipsey is a big you know uh you know
plus one of the people he really look up
to in the music business so of course
you know if you have puff wanting to
work with you and you know add certain
elements to the project
you're going to let him jump in and do
that so you know i think it was just
inspiration based um
is there a lot of like is there
because we had j stone up here and he
said that there's obviously a lot of
unreleased nipsey music out there
or not out there but you know stuff that
he recorded
is there going to be any sort of
album you know we we've gotten a pop
smoke album
i mean tupac passed and we got a i mean
[ __ ] we know how many albums
he put out after he died but is there
any any discussions of
even exploring that i mean you know
everybody
knows how big of a perfectionist nipsey
was
and you know from me i i wouldn't be
comfortable
being involved with putting out no more
nipsey music in the future because
he's not there he's not there to approve
it and i don't want to stand on this
thinking that i'm powerful enough to say
no that's what he would have wanted
so if black sam or somebody his family
or you know somebody that you know that
i feel like could make that call wants
to do it of course i would help out but
i would never want like i think he left
the legacy that's so crazy in that last
project i just wouldn't want to cloud it
that's fair you know was because um
racks in the middle
was a record that kind of came out as
like a lucy was that supposed to
be the first single for the next prize
of the next project right
yeah yeah we're about to start doing
more features
and like damn man yeah because i
remember when he dropped the record he
came up to the station and
and i was like yo so is this the sequel
he's like it's just a song for now you
know like we go
yeah damn i mean especially with the
success they had you already know that
with a catapult into
and we had yeah some [ __ ] it's crazy
talk to me about roddy because it's
funny because nipsey was actually the
first person that ever introduced me to
roddy ridge
and and and i have one of my uh friends
from phoenix
jd films shot all of roddy's first video
so he did like
die like all the early [ __ ] so i kind of
been up on him
you know i remember when you guys first
signed him i've already been kind of hip
to what he was doing
um you brought roddy into the fold in
atlantic
yeah how did you end up meeting roddy
rich give us that
you know because i feel like roddy's one
of them ones that you know
whenever he drops it's over yeah for
sure i'm definitely looking forward to
that
so um you know um after
all the stuff was going on just like
with the success with all the artists i
was really
in a space where i wanted to find
something new and work with something
from scratch
and when you when you guys started
working together it wasn't like roddy
was like he didn't have a [ __ ] ton of
fun
one song he had 3 000 followers yeah i
was going to say like i remember like
like when i saw that i was like yo
that's dope that he got that you
[ __ ] with him because i remember
looking at his followers i was already
following him i remember he only had
like 10
000 followers or something yeah so i had
a couple of interns at the time
one was kiefer yeah and i met kefa
through nipsey
so um nipsey was just telling me you
know he's a good doodle but i really
didn't know much about kiefer
and um kiefer was very consistent as far
as um you know building a relationship
with me
um so um i got him an internship to work
with me
and um you know with all my interns the
main goal is to kind of like i set up
like accounts for them to go through
beats so i have people send me beats and
and every week i'd be like yo bring two
or three artists to me that you [ __ ]
with that you've seen online or whatever
and we could go over and go through
music
and roddy was one of the artists that
keith was saw on youtube
so when he played it for me i was like
yo find the kid and let's figure out get
him in the studio and see what he could
do
um he reached out got roddy in the
studio
played me a couple records and i was
like oh this kid is amazing so i went to
the studio
to see roddy in action and he did like
three or four songs and one night
i couldn't believe it like wow because a
lot of artists you know
they can't make music that consistently
and you know they always got excuses oh
something's wrong i've been in the
studio artist
it's like like you'll be in the studio
for eight hours and you came away with
one record
yeah so right then i knew i was just
like
yo man i gotta get this kid signed
because he's just he's special and um
craig hellman happened to be in la
during this time and um i just took a
meet with craig and craig was like if
you want to do it just do it
and you got the deal done do you feel
like that that is the
the because you know we look back at nip
and nip
had been a name he was obviously i mean
he was in the hip-hop world
prior to victory lap you know he was
already a staple um
but roddy rich was someone who you
like we like not no one knew who roddy
rich was
yeah you know what i'm saying and i
think that that's when i when i think of
like
labels and like where things are now
it feels like the days of that kind of
[ __ ] happening are gone
yeah like you gotta already have all
this [ __ ] going on at least through
analytics that's still a good sign i was
gonna say even simba you know we can get
to simmon a little bit but like
that's why i i appreciate that about you
and your track record
is like someone like roddy rich yeah
like you guys really built
like roddy built from the ground up you
know what i'm saying like you guys built
with him
and and dropped mixtapes with them and
there was
every everything was was it was i mean
to
you know for lack of better words it was
like a marathon not a sprint you know
what i'm saying
yep for sure do you think that that kind
of like roddy rich kind of
and his success kind of changed your
career and like people's like
like yo like dallas really know i mean
obviously it's easy
absolutely absolutely because every time
i had success with you know the mmg
situation
they always gave ross credit well yes
mmg ross is high yeah yeah
they're like but people don't understand
i'm in the studio with the artists that
ross is still an artist at the time so
like i'm day to day with everyone
so it's like you know i was like damn i
ain't really getting dealing with the
nipsy [ __ ] i was like nipsey still was
nipsy even though what we did with
victory lab was special and you know
even getting him to sign
with a major was a big deal and [ __ ]
like that so i feel like the writing
[ __ ] was like okay
this was done with nothing from scratch
you know what i'm saying so i think that
was just very important with people
realizing like okay
what can we say about him now you know
what i'm saying to kind of put everybody
the critics to the to the sideline um do
you remember
talk about because roddy's album
you know one of the biggest albums of
the last 10 years
the box is one of the biggest yeah the
is the
is when ronnie did the box did he go
back in and add the eat
like like no he had that from jump so
that was already in there i was already
in there
when you heard like he did that like
when he recorded like roddy does
voices in a lot of his songs that people
are going to start realizing
as far as like when he keeps more music
out but he's always
he always does [ __ ] like that that was
like his idea that wasn't part of the
beat
absolutely no it was not part of the
beat it was alrighty's idea it's funny
because i was um
i was in hawaii on my honeymoon when the
album came out and that was the record i
remember
everybody was talking about i forget
which record was a big feature on it
but i remember telling dj amen like bro
i'm in hawaii
riding around in a convertible this this
the box [ __ ] is the one bro like
it's so crazy because that was like one
of the last two records he recorded
before he turned in his projects so we
already had a
a rollout plan with everything besides
the box
damn that's why the video took so long
to get out
it's crazy because i haven't seen an
artist
besides i think kendrick's damn record
as far as like
songs that just ran radio for as long
like
high fashion balling the bot like these
records are still like in power rotation
in radio stations
absolutely it's like they research like
it's in it's insane bro it's
it's it's crazy uh
i mean he's been teasing this new feed
the street [ __ ] is that what is that
what's next
i hope so you hope so how much how many
records are you sitting on
at least a hundred a hundred at least
ronnie does like five songs a day
it's crazy he makes so much music like
rodney could
he walk in here right now set up a
studio right here and make 10 songs
that [ __ ] is on this table yeah it's
it's it's it's he's like one of those
you know i i tell people there's a few
artists
that it's hard for them to make a bad
song yeah you have like roddy's like
[ __ ] like you listen to all his [ __ ]
like it's like hard for
i feel like post malone is one of those
guys where like there might be some post
malone songs you might not [ __ ] with
yeah but it's hard for postman to make a
shitty song like roddy rich
like roddy's one of them artists who's
like just his melodies are so
crazy like the way he can float on a
verse
nah he's special he's he's he's
definitely you know like he's like one
of those artists that come around every
ten years a hundred percent you know
100 were you uh you know with with the
uh
the lack of grammy nomination for for
for the rap album of the year was that
something that you kind of took personal
i don't really take the grammy stuff
personal no more
i just you know at the end of the day
man like i think
we do music to kind of um you know for
the culture and to feed our families and
things like that i don't really know
we got a grammy with rex in the middle
of course so
you know that was a highlight moment but
you know
at the end of the day like just seeing
the success that
roddy has now and you know just the kind
of way he's living life is just
that's the the dope [ __ ] to see are you
instrumental in the new in the new music
he's working on or she's kind of just
doing his thing
he's doing his thing i think i think
right he's at the point where you know
him and keefa are kind of so locked in
i'm just whenever they need me i'm here
i'm here but
you know whatever they need from me of
course but you know
i don't think roddy needs help from
anybody that's fair
so um some of the uh newer artists that
you're working with
um i know you're you're playing a part
in corde's new music
yep working on choreography i've heard
some stuff with some
he's got some crazy features we won't
talk about those but he's definitely got
some
[ __ ] yeah that he's that that is in the
can
um and then simba yes so simba is
somebody who
you know you're really kind of helping
like
i it reminds me of the rowdy situation
yes and simba you know somebody who we
had what year did we have simba on the
show 2017
yeah something like that it is a while
ago but simba's somebody who
has been around yeah but like
i feel like was kind of like a like an
unpolished gem
yeah that was just sitting around that
like you know it just need like somebody
needed to just come along and be like
yo yeah let's let's do this [ __ ] it was
it was crazy because um
me a similar relationship started off
real organic um
so his producer he has a producer named
cass and i'm super cool yeah shout out
to homie cassidy
yes cass what's up he was hitting me
and he's like excuse me he's like i got
this artist man i think he's the next
jay-z
it's a lot to say right so i'm like man
so you know when you get these calls at
the a
r you'll be like yeah sure all right man
yeah
you got the next hoes right and they'd
be your friends too so you just be like
hi man you know what i'm saying so he's
telling me like man so
i'm like man there's no way you have the
next hole bro
so anyways i do this a little thing at
um
my office it was called past the arts
where i had like mad
music producers and writers come and i
have food and drinks for everybody and
we just was in the conference room
playing music
and simple step to the auction court and
start playing me his music and i was
just looking like oh this kid is
different you know what i'm saying i
just knew he had a different energy
and sim just a likable person definitely
so
when um i set up a meeting with him the
next day
and he played me some more [ __ ] and i
was just blown away and i was like we
going to new york next week took him to
new york next week and just signed him
wow like i think julie heard two records
she said welcome to atlanta records i'm
like damn julie you gotta
you're showing all your cards so julie
loved him immediately
the whole staff loved him and you know
like if the kova [ __ ] didn't happen last
year i think you know sim
he would even be further ahead than he
is right now yeah i think
like you know because i remember talking
to him and and i think you know
obviously a lot of the stuff you guys
had planned kind of got
yeah got rearranged yes but i think it
all worked out
yeah i mean really that la leakers
freestyle is i think what really kind of
showed everybody like
absolutely absolutely this [ __ ]
is here
like who is this guy we got so much love
from that man and just like you know the
the feedback was great and you know the
project i'm you know we really excited
for our first project
so now i think the goal is just stay
consistent with the music and just
getting music out and some of those
records that he played that
those are still coming in yeah they're
still coming out they were just going
through sample clearances that are clear
now so we got a lot of [ __ ] why
why didn't so there was a record that
was supposed to be on his album called
west side griselda
yeah why didn't that it was the
yeah another artist who you're working
with yeah so jason cash somebody else
that i'm working with right now not
assigned from the west coast
so i'm super excited about him but i met
him through simba yep him assembled
we're making a lot of music
together and i just loved his energy and
[ __ ] i mean the music he's been making
has been crazy like i'm really excited
for everybody to hear his [ __ ] too
so you know we doing something special
man i got a studio out here we called
the trap
yep yep yeah and you know it's just like
a great music space where
you know creators could come and it's no
egos and everybody's working together
because we're all trying to see each
other win
so you know when we when people come
there man it's just special music that's
being made
who's somebody who you tried to sign
that didn't work out
that you kind of were like ah that
almost happened oh gee
polo g yep damn that would have been
crazy
i was probably it was out of me and one
other label
and i didn't push the button on um
something that i should have did that i
regret to this day
and um he went with the other label
instead
so something so it was it was close i
was there he was in the atlantic office
and everything we were close i had him
come to the studio and then the night
he came to the studio i had meet roddy
working again like it was one of those
nights so
you know that's one that you wish you
could get back man
yeah i can only imagine i'm a big fan of
himself yo
has you know somebody who i heard you
know um
someone who who jason cash got a great
relationship with yeah it's blast
yes blast from my knowledge is still not
signed
no i don't think that's true i know he
was with red bull yeah
but i but maybe maybe since the last
time i talked to him some [ __ ] has
changed
yeah but i feel like blast is one of
them once he's incredible
him and cash got to smash together they
gotta smash yes
jason was telling me stories about like
he was just bringing blast everywhere
back in the day yeah they got a dope
relationship man so it's glad to see
like
them go their own ways and come back
together you know what i'm saying so
it's it's dope to see for people
watching this who
are artists or for you know i always
tell artists that there's really no
excuse for you to not
be on your [ __ ] in 2020 2021 because
you know the internet from from from
when you first got in we were talking
earlier you you know
the days of like you needing to meet
someone and pass them your tape or
all that shit's gone like you know
you're straight to consumer now but like
what are the things that
that you would tell up and coming
artists um that they need to have
like together you know what i'm saying
to be taken serious
i mean you know what bothers me a lot of
um coming
artists don't even take the time to
figure out who the players are in the
game
so you know like i hate when people come
up to me and they'd be like oh you
working me what do you do like it'd be
like then they'd be like oh can you take
i'm like i'm not about to explain what i
do today right like you know like
when i was coming up i knew who
everybody was at every label
so if i didn't run into them i would
know something about their story
to be compelling enough for them to want
to take my information
nowadays that's why i dm you'll be like
bruh
what is that move right right right now
i'm saying so
i mean honestly you know i think what
helped me best was being a student of
the game and realizing what people did
before me
to get to where they're at you know
reading books and things like that
to kind of help put me on the path to
understanding what it takes to be good
at what i do but
you know i think just understanding that
and just work ethic
you know the entitlement is is an
all-time high
all-time high right now it's very it's
very concerning for me
you know what i'm saying because on the
artist side and on the and on the
background like on
you know like on your side yes it's bad
man like you know
everybody wants to the big salary big
check but don't want to check in
that's all [ __ ] you know who what do you
look for in an artist when when you when
when
you know is it obviously metrics aside
because we've already established that
that's not
that's not the end i'll be all for you
what do you look for um
i like when so right now we're in
a wave of you know i want to say
baby rotties of course you know what i'm
saying um
i like when there's like a wave of music
on and i hear something that's going
completely
in the other direction that's why symbol
was dope for me at the time because
nobody was rapping no more
it was it was everybody mumble rap was
big and
you know all these little whatevers you
know what i'm saying
i feel like even the guys who get credit
as like good rappers now aren't even
really good rappers yeah they're just
good rappers compared to like
what's going on yeah like outside of
like the griseldas and like the gibbs
and all that [ __ ] but like
on the mainstream side there's like
people who really get credit for being
like dope that aren't even that dope i'm
like
they're dope for like compared to who
you know what i'm saying so
so you like that original the
originality yeah i just like when
something like when there's a wave going
i like somebody that's going in a total
different direction
that's fair you know that's fair uh
what's next for you man
right next is for is for me is um really
turning asylum into a powerhouse
label um breaking some acts this year um
i got cider baby and candy man
it's my first two acts on my asylum
roster that are a priority for me
so making sure that um you know their
projects are amazing
and you know helping them whatever i
could do you just signed a kid
from indiana too i just signed a kid
named j low from indianapolis he he's on
some trap soul [ __ ] that's incredible
um and of course i got simon and jason
cash that are up next for me and cordee
as well
so uh saw the baby
yes that was somebody who was already on
asylum when you got
ken the man was yep right so you i
remember you told me you're like yo when
i found out
that ken the man was on the roster i'm
like yo this is this is yeah this is a
slam dunk right here absolutely what is
how is it working with soda baby i've
had
some really interesting experiences with
him we did an interview here that never
came out because he was falling asleep
throughout the whole interview okay
night i don't know or it could have been
what was in his cup one or the two
but he's a very funny dude um
and then he there was he booked the
studio one night and
they had bro oh my god
they booked both rooms [ __ ] was this
this was like
june yeah no like covert was not even a
thing like
my engineers are hitting me like what do
we do i'm like nothing it's a rap studio
we're gonna get one of these every once
in a while absolutely but what's it like
you know
yeah so my first time working with um
soda was last week he came to l.a for a
week and worked and you know man i
really got to just understand this
process
um he's a very hard worker i think he
has a vision to
you know his madness of course um
and i think he just wants to be
respected as
a dope artist in his music game you know
i'm saying he's putting out a lot of
records a lot of content
and um you know i just think that this
year is going to be one of those years
that i think he's going to break as one
of the big artists in the game for sure
and then ken the man is uh she's from
houston yeah kenneman's exciting because
i never got by the way
it's a female and her name's ken the man
yeah it was confusing yeah so i guess
the the whole personas you know
she she she could get on her her man
with the ladies you know
her her manager melissa hit me and was
like yo can i bring ken the man up this
was
what a year and a half or two ago and i
was like yeah what's his instagram she's
oh it's a girl
i was like what the [ __ ] but then she
came and spazzed the [ __ ] out
yes yeah that freestyle was dope as [ __ ]
she did with you yeah she's incredible
so be on the lookout for her
um and then are you currently like are
you always looking for talent
i'm always looking for a talent but now
you know like as i'm like
getting higher up as far as just like i
got a team i got art i got an rs now so
you know of course they're bringing
stuff to my attention every day but
you know i got to really make sure i'm
balancing what i have the right way
because i don't want to get so many
artists that i'm losing focus
on you know the artists i have is asylum
going to kind of
act also as like like a distribution
platform for yes
for some artists kind of like in the in
the way that like there's like empire
absolutely absolutely so you're going to
be doing some distro and then if
something really starts moving that's
when the upstream happens yeah
yeah it's it's it's it's great for me
because i could do so many unique deals
i could do
joint ventures 50 50 split 70 30 splits
like just it depends what an artist
wants what services they want
and you know what they want to bring to
the table because you know if you want
to stay independent you want to do a
one-off mixtape to see if you even like
how we structured over there at asylum
and things like that it gives the
opportunity to get
you know into the system see if they
like it and don't be tied down for five
or six albums and saying [ __ ] the label
on their next tweet
well historically asylum is known as a
hip-hop label
back in the day it was like bun b and i
mean i was mike jones on the side
mike john yeah mike jones yeah right is
that are you strictly looking for
hip-hop
mike jones who's mike jones yeah mike
jones um
i mean i'm definitely gonna keep it
hip-hop you know what i'm saying but i
do want to do some
progressive r b [ __ ] you know i'm saying
i think jaylata's
a great artist that we're going to
introduce to the world that's going to
really
you know show that trap soul cause i
think trap soul is going to become like
a real force in the music business right
now
you know what i'm saying like artists
yeah someone just said that should be
his own john i forget who tweeted that
yeah trap soul is i think um quavo did
cuevo
yeah by the way shout out to bryson
tiller he the first one
yeah for sure he definitely opened up
the door for it you know what i'm saying
so a lot of these artists man you know
they from the street
but they sing do you find it hard
balancing because you're a family man
i'm a family man
i feel like it's it's hard to kind of
balance being
a boss and moving around and like kind
of that work life balance is that like
how do you how do you
kind of do that man cause it's tough
it's tough man i mean
[ __ ] it's like you know um i have to
really just
make sure that i only go to the studio
like i can't really hang out with my
artists as much as i want to
when they're going to clubs and things
like that i really just have to focus on
the office and be
with them in the studio it's got to be
something special yeah it has to be
something worth it like you know what
i'm saying i can't just go to the club
with you because y'all taking some hoes
out
yeah i'm saying so like i'm assuming you
won't be going to all-star weekend
exactly right right right like that like
there's no point for me to be yeah like
what am i going out there for
yeah yeah that's fair yeah that's you
got to pick and choose
those those moments absolutely i feel
you i'm on that same [ __ ] yeah
so you know things that make sense for
me to be at like
if i have an artist doing something
special in the city that they you know
they want to mean something
that means i'll be there but you know a
lot of artists respect that
i do have a family you know what i'm
saying so they're going to make sure
that you know they're going to let me
know things they want to be at but
you know i think artists main focus is
me being in the studio with them opposed
to the club
boom well look dallas appreciate your
time yep appreciate you man thanks for
having me man this is good fun
yeah man i think your story's dope and i
think you know i always tell everybody
like yo dallas like
you your come up has been crazy to
witness bro so absolutely appreciate it
podcast wrapping up boom thank you man
perfect
yeah man had a good time bro